promixité vous est présenté par NG
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur l'Espagne en passe de devenir un
modèle en matière de parité le
gouvernement en effet décideré de
frapper fort avec un projet de loi qui
oblige les entreprises côté à un
équilibre dans les conseils
d'administration une règle qui s'étendra
au postees à responsabilité pour toutes
les entreprises de plus de 250 salariés
et au chiffre d'affaires qui dépassent
les 50 millions d'euros rappelons
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes occupent 32 %
des sièges dans les conseils
d'administration des compagnies de l'bex
35 le fameux indice boursier de Madrid
mais n'y représente que 22 % des hauts
dirigeants la loi entrera en vigueur
progressivement à partir de cet été pour
atteindre la parité parfaite à l'été
2026 à noté qu'elle prévoit également
plus de parité en politique avec un
minimum de 40 % de femmes au sein du
gouvernement des obligations qui
concerneront aussi les organismes
publics voilà ProMix cité c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite sur public
SCA promixité vous a été présenté par
ngj acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle